[Music]
Canadian actress Ellen Page has been
speaking out on LGBTQ rights for a long
time in 2016
Ellen hosted the vice land series gay
keishon which was an eye-opening look at
LGBTQ cultures around the world here we
are in Rio de Janeiro Brazil and despite
seeming like a place that is sexually
open the issues that LGBTQ people face
can be really horrific in recent years
ellen has not been shy to speak her mind
which is exactly what she did while
recently appearing on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert if you are in a position
of power and you hate people and you
want to cause suffering to them you go
through the trouble you spend your
career trying to cause suffering what do
you think is gonna happen kids are gonna
be abused and they're gonna kill
themselves and people are gonna be
beaten on the street I have traveled the
world and I have met the most
marginalized people you could be I am
lucky to have this time and the
privilege to say this this needs to stop
that kind of emotion cannot be faked
even by an actress which is why when
Ellen caught wind of Chris Pratt
appearing on that same program talking
highly about his church well she tweeted
this oh okay
but his church is infamously anti LGBTQ
so maybe in a dress that - did you
follow this by saying in another tweet
if you are a famous actor and you belong
to an organization that hates a certain
group of people don't be surprised if
someone simply wonders why it's not
addressed being anti LGBTQ is wrong
there are two sides the damage it causes
is severe full stop sending love to all
it's no surprise that tweet was liked by
more than 200,000 Twitter users and when
Chris caught wind of it he posted this
to his own Instagram story
to sum up Chris's lengthy post he says
nothing could be further from the truth
I go to a church that opens their doors
to absolutely
everyone crisps regularly attends o a
church with his new fiance Catherine
Schwarzenegger Zoey is part of the
Hillsong Church family were Justin
Bieber and many other celebrities attend
a pastor from Hillsong once wrote in a
blog titled do I love gay people that he
believes God's Word is clear that
marriage is between a man and a woman
and that Hillsong Church welcomes all
people but does not affirm all
lifestyles so yes maybe the church opens
its doors to absolutely everyone but
once inside will they tell LGBTQ members
not to get married to someone of the
same gender or denounce transgender
identities yeah it's likely I caught up
with Ellen on the red carpet for the
premiere of the Umbrella Academy last
night and thanked her for using her
voice for the LGBTQ community that means
a lot I really really appreciate it it
doesn't go unnoticed I want you to know
that well thank you for doing that as
well yeah we really have to we have to
be there for each other and yeah speak
about what's going on and have these
conversations now it's important to
remember that Ellen was not taking aim
at any faith with just Chris Pratt's
choice of church what do you think of
Ellen's speaking out should celebrities
speak their minds is Chris Pratt trying
to bend the truth do you think Ellen is
a great voice for the LGBTQ community
let me know in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe to e to
Canada's YouTube page